Isabelle is in Houston Texas I as well
how are you oh I'm starstruck I'm really
good how are you well I'm honored how
can I help
I'm really trying to figure things out
I'm on baby step three I've got about
four to five months of expenses paid I'm
currently in between jobs but I am gonna
be opening my own business and I'm
wondering how I should fund it a
break-even point is in about three to
four months and after having everything
for the business operating cost and
paying employees profit should be about
70 grand a year I'm wondering if I
should get a part-time job
and take out a loan because startup
costs are only about 15 to 17 grand or
if I should take a take on a full-time
job and do that for a few years and then
pay those startup cost and pull and then
switch to part-time when I get things
built up you've done a really good job
of analyzing this and doing your initial
forecasts on your income what makes you
think they're right that that's accurate
based on the area the amount of people
that are in this area I would only need
to get 95 customers a day at 450 a sale
and I think that's over overly doable
especially in the area that I'm in and
I've done a little bit of the market
research and there's not and there's not
any places selling what I'm selling so
there's no real set of data it's just a
gut feel and based on the market size of
the demand of the product that 95 is
what you think you would do you could
have just as easily do 150 you could
just as easily do 30 pretty much I've
done some research I've gone to similar
businesses that have the same set up and
I asked them what their you know their
sales are per day and they said you know
they're around on the low side 600 on
the high side 900 in the same region in
the same business that's the same
business selling the same product no but
it's the same industry
I'll be selling coffee and beignets from
a food truck and this is just some food
trucks that are also in in the area oh I
got you okay and so if we take employees
out of it and you just do it mm-hmm
what does that save you for the first
few months if I'm taking employees out
my gross per month should be about ten
to sixty so ten thousand two hundred and
sixty dollars and then operating cost
should be about let's eat board uh six
hundred bucks
mm-hmm okay so your labor cost is pretty
substantial then as a portion of this
percentage-wise okay and so the startup
is the purchase of the truck startup
would be all the permit fees all the
classes I would do to get the proper
permits and stuff that is for two County
women located in a tri-county area you
have to take a class to get a permit to
sell coffee in Texas no it's just a food
it's a manager certification food safety
course I've already done that once but I
was gonna have someone else that could
take that course so when I am ready to
hire them they're ready to go also you
know the LLC tax ID that comes to about
a thousand to two hundred and sixty
dollars and then oh stop stop stop stop
stop stop stop let me go back okay you
already have the certification the
manager certification you were just
talking about paying someone else to do
it right okay so I got not hiring
anybody right right now we don't any
money so we're not hiring anybody you're
gonna do the work and you've already got
certification so we we just drop labor
costs and we just drop that and LLC does
not cost a thousand dollars to put
together go to us legal forms comment
you don't even need an LLC LLC is 350
and then the permits or the the mobile
food unit firm
inspection fees are about 910 dollars
total okay but yeah a tax ID number is
free by the way and you don't even know
no you don't need an LLC to start with
you could do an LLC later if you want to
it's not you're just not required to
have an LLC it's just risk management
very interesting okay so the truck costs
what the equipment is a trailer you say
well the trailer I'm gonna be building
it and that's kind of where my
background is so I'll be building the
trailer and that should probably run me
about thirty five hundred dollars and
then all the equipment is going to be
about twelve thousand the equipment to
do what the oven or somethin or the deep
fryer the vent hood sink how much have
you got in your emergency fund I'm sorry
how much is in your emergency fund right
now five thousand dollars and forty five
thousand forty four dollars okay
thought you said you had four months of
expenses okay well my expenses are about
nine hundred dollars a month so almost
all of the seventeen thousand is the
trailer and the equipment okay I'll tell
you what you have done so very well you
have you have line-item this out you
know the answers to these questions you
you are living this dream it's going to
happen because you've you you have
you've put it down I mean you've laid it
down you've laid it out you've got it
all figured out I never tell people to
borrow money to start a business and I'm
not gonna tell you to borrow money to
start a business and that so my only
thing that it restores running through
my head then is how fast can we how can
we make some money really really fast it
because I need about 15 grand to get you
going is all I would imagine you can
probably pick up the equipment some of
it used even or refurbished it even
cheaper than you're talking about
couldn't you oh yeah absolutely I was
just kind of going off
scenario going off of a worst-case
scenario because I'm trying to find the
money to get this thing going mm-hmm you
know so you probably do it probably cut
that equipment cost by at least 25 or 30
percent couldn't you yeah all right so
we're done we're getting down close to
10 grand now I don't want you to spend
your last dollar your emergency fund to
do this and you said you're not working
right now I am currently in between jobs
I had a sales job making about twenty
five hundred to three grand a month
and then I had a buddy of mine that said
hey come on I'll get you into management
and then we'll put you on salary and
you'll go up the chain of command but
things didn't quite pan out that way and
so now I'm like should I take another
sales jobs or some money yes I should I
take a part-time job and really followed
this dream all the way through I want
you to take a sales job make some money
and follow this dream all the way
through as soon as you possibly can
scratch them lay together live on beans
and rice and build this trailer and get
this thing going you'll have it going by
March you really think I really think so
it may be April I could be wrong but I
think that's where you're headed you're
a rock star
Isabelle you're gonna do this and I want
you to call me back and get in let me
know how to I'm gonna come drink a cup
of your coffee next time I'm in Houston
so hold on I'm gonna give you a copy of
Chris Christie's book business boutique
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]